Speaker 1: Making his triumphant return today,
defiant and triumphant, I would say to The
David Pakman Show is Andrew Yang, entrepreneur
turned politician, author of the new book
Foreword Notes on the Future of Our Democracy,
which I was glad, glad to take a look at a
couple of weeks ago when you sent it to me.
Former Democratic presidential primary candidate,
former New York City mayoral candidate.
I mean, there's just so much to talk about,
but it's great having you back on.
Speaker 4: Thanks, David.
It's great to be here.
It's been so long, been far too long.
Speaker 1: It has.
So you know, you and I, we have many things
in common and many things not in common.
One of the things we have in common is we
are pragmatists.
Speaker 4: You both run for president.
David, is that that would happen?
Speaker 1: I can't.
I'm a naturalized citizen, so I cannot do
it.
That is something I unless the law changes,
I will never be able to do sadly.
But but in our pragmatism, I think we both
prioritize solving problems and that comes
through in the book.
It came through in your presidential campaign,
etc. to solve problems.
We've got to figure out what created the problem.
So to what do you attribute the current division
that exist politically in the United States?
Speaker 4: In a word, David incentives.
But one of the things I found in researching
and writing my book was that this is not normal.
We are not in normal times.
If you rewind a number of decade, well, if
you go way back to the founding of the country,
then they're not fans of political parties.
The Republican Party comes about in the wake
of the Civil War starts out as the Northern
Anti-Slavery Party.
But the two parties, despite trading power
back and forth for about 100 years, were kind
of indistinguishable ideologically until the
1960s, reorganize things somewhat with the
civil rights movement.
And then you have the end of the Fairness
Doctrine, the beginning of cable TV in the
90s.
And so the two parties have started diverging
ideologically and politically really over
the last 30, 40 years or so.
And that's given rise to the urban rural divide,
the educated, less educated divide.
But all of the political incentives now are
around the extremes because eighty three percent
plus of the congressional races are decided
in the primary.
So in each party, in order to get reelected,
you just want to not get primaried, which
means you're going to be trying to keep people
off your back in the extreme flank of your
party.
See this very clearly with the Republicans,
where if someone says a bad word about Trump,
they then get attacked and cast out.
So you have these political incentives around
the extremes and then you have media incentives
compounding those extremes by separating us
into ideological army camps at this point.
And then you have social media on top of it.
So this is why we feel like we're careening
towards political violence and worse.
And I just want to commend folks like you
because I do see independent media as the
antidote.
Like, you all aren't as ideological or inflammatory
in many cases.
Of course, there are people that I like that,
but not you, David.
So that so that the polarization we're feeling
is now a very predictable result of all of
the political and media incentives that are
driving the system.
Speaker 1: OK.
I mostly, you know, small issues I could take
with that, but for our discussion today, basically
agree with with the assessment.
So we then get to the forward movement, the
forward party, bridging this gap, finding
something that maybe can cross the traditional
party lines that more people can agree with.
First question is what is it that you think
would be appealing to people from these two
sometimes ideological extremes, sometimes
just ideological differences?
Speaker 4: Well, I would say that polarization
is a bad thing for everyone.
Let's say you are on the left and you'd like
to get something done on climate change and
you're like, Why can we not get anything done
on climate change?
A Republican senator said something to me
that really hit home.
She said, Andrew, we get rewarded more for
keeping an issue around than resolving it.
And the example I have been using is Marco
Rubio suggesting immigration reform and then
he had shipped by the Republican Party is
saying never mind, never mind, nothing to
see.
So if you are on the left and you're like,
why can't we do things that 60, 70, 70 percent
of us want, then you'd want to try and reform
the system to become more rational and more
responsive to the desire of the majority of
us.
And you can go down the list on issues that
you know, immigration, you go climate.
Well, let's take climate change.
Speaker 1: I mean, so I think this is where
we might have our first disagreement.
Completely agree with you that the Senate,
the system by explicitly and implicitly with
things like the term limits that we have almost
always having to be campaigning for your next
election.
All these different things don't prioritize
solutions to long term problems like climate
change.
I agree with everything you've said.
And yet?
Part of climate change is a huge portion of
one side doesn't believe it's real, or if
they do, they don't believe humans are a factor.
So this is where I get to.
Your analysis is great.
I don't think it accounts for it's more than
that when one side simply won't accept the
science.
How do you get those people to buy in?
Speaker 4: All right.
So let's play this out.
Yeah.
What proportion of Americans don't believe
that climate change is real or caused by humans?
Speaker 1: The last I've seen, it's I wish
I had the data in front of me.
I think it's about half or 60 percent of Republicans
don't believe it's caused by humans and maybe
25 33 percent something like that.
Don't believe it's even happening at all.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
So that lines up with what I thought the numbers
were roughly.
So let's imagine that you have a gross numbers.
Thirty five percent of Americans who either
don't think climate change is caused by humans
or it's not a big deal or whatever it is,
and that that percentage is declining happily
or unhappily because it's becoming so apparent
apparent around us.
Yeah.
So right now you have a Republican Party that
is motivated by that.
You know, let's call it for for argument's
sake, roughly half of the Republican Party
are bit more.
Does not think climate change is something
we should do anything about.
Sure.
The problem is that that relative minority
ends up controlling the agenda for half of
the country and then can stall any real move
to change it.
Yes.
So let's say hypothetically, instead of having
two parties, we had four parties or five parties
and you had progressive Democrats, moderate
Democrats, forward ists, moderate Republicans
and conservative Republicans.
And the conservative would be like, Hey, climate
change bonds, let's not do a thing.
But then you'd have four or other groups look
up and say, we should do something about it.
So what you're seeing here is is not quite
the minority rule, but its minority veto or
its minority keeping anything from happening.
And so this is the system as it currently
is made up.
So the thing that I want people to come to
grips with is that politics right now is completely
tribal and you can be very, very angry at
what another tribe says or feels.
But the problem right now is that we only
have two tribes, and it doesn't take much
to gum up the works, which is why we're all
losing our minds, getting more polarized and
frustrated.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And so this this gets us to really a discussion
of third parties.
And I'm curious, I have a view as to why third
parties have not become more significant at
the national level.
I'm curious what what your view is.
My view is it's essentially two things.
It's not for lack of want of more options.
It's not for lack of political diversity.
It's not because of the desire for more political
diversity in the major parties.
People want that.
It's two things one that the the side whose
third party does best ultimately risks being
a spoiler and people who say I'd like a third.
This is the age old Green Party thing.
I mean, this is not new, right?
Oh, I like this.
It probably gets the people I really don't
want in power if it goes well and no to connect
it to that how politics is financed in the
United States as well.
Those are, for me, the two main reasons why.
What do you see
Speaker 4: in a word, incentives?
So if you if you decide to break from the
two major parties, all of a sudden you don't
have capital structure, you don't have votes,
you don't have media and you're in the wilderness.
Now I do want to return to the you're going
to mess it up for whatever team you're closer
to.
This is one reason why the first big move
the forward party is making is to push for
a ranked choice voting combined with open
primaries, because if you had ranked choice
voting in an election, you could vote green
one Democrat to Republican three and then
no, no one needs to worry about it.
The problem right now is that the duopoly
wants to stifle any competition, and it uses
fear.
It's like if I had a buck for every time someone
said, Oh, you're going to mess it up for the
Democrats, even though the numbers do not
make it clear that that's exactly what I'd
be doing, and I have said absolutely nothing
about, you know, a national race like, I'm
trying to get things done at the local level
four for 22.
But if you were to shift to ranked choice
voting, then the spoiler effect disappears,
which is exactly why we need it and also exactly
why the duopoly doesn't want to talk about
it.
Because to your point, at this point, a majority
of Americans want to move on from the duopoly.
We know it's not working.
But we just keep being told we can't have
it because of this archaic voting system that
we could change.
If enough of us got together to say, Look,
let's just do everything by ranked choice
voting, no more spoiler effect.
But the parties don't want that because the
parties know that we actually don't like them
very much.
The only reason we're choosing a is because
they're trying to scare us about me.
Speaker 1: So the question then becomes, How
do you?
I mean, this is sort of like when an elected
official says, As soon as I get in, I'm going
to do voting, you know, election reform and
campaign finance reform.
It's like, hold on a second, you're going
to come to power under the system we have
and then.
Change the system that worked to get you,
empower it to go to incentives.
It doesn't seem like you'll be super incentivized
to do that.
The same question sort of applies here.
If we need to make the changes you're talking
about to campaign finance and how votes are
counted first past the post in order to make
the third party more reasonable, more viable,
how are we going to make those changes?
Speaker 4: So the forward party has two major
endeavors in 2022.
OK.
Number one is that and it turns out because
the political parties are made up that we
could actually get together and change to
an open primary ranked choice voting at the
state level.
Yes, in 24 states around the country have
just had enough of us got together.
And for people who think like, Oh, this will
never happen, it happened last year in one
state, Alaska 2020 changed from party primaries
to open primaries and ranked choice voting,
and you immediately saw the result when Senator
Lisa Murkowski of Alaska voted to impeach
Donald Trump.
The only Republican senator to do so who's
up for reelection in 2022?
Her approval rating among Alaskan Republicans
is now six percent, so it is genuinely politically
suicidal for a Republican to go against Trump,
but she can skip the party primary.
It doesn't exist anymore.
You have an open primary so she can take her
case the entire Alaskan public and then say,
Look like I'm an independent person, bring
me back.
So if we make the same change that Alaska
made in three, four or five states around
the country in 2022, imagine six eight 10
senators, some of them Republican, who are
then free of the thrall of their party, free
to do what they think is right.
Maybe they'll even support protecting secretaries
of state from election interference.
You know, like I said, this is something we
can do if we had enough Americans get together
and do what they did in Alaska.
So that's step one, which we don't have to
wait for anyone to do.
We can do it right now.
There are none of us.
So that's what the Foreign Party is about
trying to gather that movement.
The second thing is we can support candidates
who are.
Fighting on principle as Democrats, independents
or Republicans, and I was going to call out
someone who I doubt people in your program
talked much about.
There is a West Virginia congressman named
David McKinley, who co-sponsored a cash relief
bill that I lobbied for and voted yes on infrastructure.
He's one of the 13 Republicans to do so.
He's now facing a fight with Trumper.
And who the heck is going to help David McKinley
like the Democrats to be like, Oh, he's a
Republican, so screw it, you know?
But I'm going to suggest that a lot of Americans
should be getting behind David McKinley and
some other reasonable Republicans who are
endangered species because they're taking
flak for doing the right thing.
Speaker 1: You mean, so that's interesting.
So you mentioned a Republican.
Is there a prominent Democrat right now that
people in my audience might know that you
think is particularly suited and tailored
for the the milieu of the forward party as
you describe it?
Speaker 4: I believe Elizabeth Warren came
out as pro ranked choice voting when it was
up on the ballot in Massachusetts last year.
So anyone who's for ranked choice voting I'm
excited about and there are a number of prominent
Democrats and democracy reformers who have
taken that stance.
I think Cory might have done so as well.
Speaker 1: I'm really curious about the coalition
that you envision to some degree.
You know, when I told my audience that you
were going to be on the most frequent question
I got in different iterations was who exactly
that currently considers themselves to be
on the right?
Does Andrew Yang imagine bringing into the
forward party and to kind of make it a little
more specific?
You know, we would imagine that there's lots
of progressive Democrats, more centrist Democrats,
even some folks who really consider themselves
centrist, maybe in the kind of line of even
like a John McCain who like the idea of some
of the reforms you're talking about.
And that all kind of makes sense to me when
I think about people who believe Donald Trump
won the election.
Vaccines, the COVID vaccine magnetize is you
causes autism, whatever the case may be, etc.,
right?
You know, the package of ideas that I'm talking
about.
One, are those people that would even conceivably
say this forward party idea that Andrew Yang
proposes in a coalition with the left makes
sense.
And number two, are these even people that
you want as part of your coalition?
Speaker 4: First, let me say, I want everyone
as part of the coalition.
You know, if you can vote, we can disagree
on a lot of things.
It's all to the good.
If we agree on the fact that this duopoly
is now working, it's designed to turn us against
each other and sink us.
So that that's one of the principles of the
Foreign Party is that, look, I can disagree
with you on a lot of stuff, but we can make
common cause on this.
Then we can go back to disagreeing when the
democracy is actually set up to succeed when
they're, you know.
Speaker 1: So let me, I mean, let me ask.
So even I mean to to make it really specific
if people on the right say the Republican
Party is too centrist, I'm an extreme white
supremacist or something like that.
But I think we need to get, you know, we need
single transferable vote or whatever and campaign
you.
You still welcome that because you're on the
same page on that one issue.
Speaker 4: Yeah, if they're going to help
us transition to a more effective democracy.
You know, I don't need to know what their
stance is on things that I disagree with.
People have a sense of where I'm coming from.
OK.
But right now, I believe that there is an
existential threat to the country as a result
of the greatest design flaw in the history
of the world.
And if you will help us resolve that design
flaw, then we can have a discussion about
anything else under the Sun at a time when
the democracy actually will stand the test
of time when we transition to a multi-party
system where you can't make any autocratic
or authoritarian decisions, you have to somehow
get two or three other parties on board.
Speaker 1: OK, all right, fair.
So on the question of is everyone literally
welcome?
The answer is yes, that's that's fine.
That's legitimate.
So that's clear.
Now, in terms of to whom that currently typically
votes for Republicans, would this appeal?
Where are you on that?
Speaker 4: There are all sorts of folks who
are displeased with Trump.
There's a person on the line who said the
other day, it's like, Look, I voted for Trump
twice, and I don't even want him back.
You know, like they're like their voters out
there who are concerned about the country.
And I've been heartened by the fact that I've
gotten a lot of incoming expressions of support
from military veterans, members of law enforcement
or former law enforcement who despair about
the state of the country.
And they see where it's going to, and they
say, this is what I've been waiting for.
There's an independent community that right
now is politically homeless.
They're very numerous.
There are 44 percent of Americans.
Consider themselves independents, and I would
say that we're seeing a lot of them come in
like one of the things I'm going to suggest.
First, if you look at the appetite for a third
party, it's higher among both Republicans
and independents and Democrats.
And so if you imagine who's going to draw
third party energy like we're where is going
to come from.
Like by the numbers, it's likely to come from
those groups and imagining that every Republican
or former Republican or independent is excited
about Trump is just not right.
You know, but but saying that that group is
also open to Democrats is also not right.
I have encountered so many Americans who just
shut down when you have a D next to your name.
Sure.
Which I found unfortunate.
But the thing I want to suggest to people
is that, again, all politics is tribal at
this point.
And so what we need to do is we need to have
more tribes emerge that we have a chance.
If we stick to two tribes, we're not.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask you about
and we're shifting gears a little bit, but
because your background in technology, I'm
very curious as to your insights, particularly
as someone who who used social media really
effectively in the Democratic primary run
that you made all the talk now about the so-called
regulation of social media.
One interesting artifact of this has been
the rapidity with which those who have for
a long time claimed businesses should be able
to do whatever they want as long as it's not
illegal.
Are now demanding that social media companies
be forced to allow messages that violate their
terms of service to be up.
That's a hypocrisy we could talk about, but
I don't want to focus on that necessarily
today.
What I'm curious about from your perspective
is what should be the regulatory infrastructure
as to the social networks, particularly from
this point of view of political bias that
Don Jr., whoever else, are regularly tweeting
about and sort of saying, We are the victims
here.
What what would you like to see?
Speaker 4: I think our government needs to
modernize its approach to social media and
technology in general.
Right now, it's behind the curve.
It's laughable or embarrassing.
This is also an outgrowth of our Jarrin autocracy,
David.
I mean, the reality is that our congressional
leaders are in their 70s or 80s.
If it is Biden vs. Trump in 2004, which it
looks like it's going in that direction, their
combined age will be one hundred and fifty
eight.
Yeah.
So then asking our government to understand
what's going on in social media is at least
right now, a bridge too far and like that
has to change.
If I were in charge, I would be getting into
the guts of these social media companies,
setting what Jonathan Height suggested as
like a filter where you end up being able
to just like, ignore people who are customarily
aggressive or obnoxious.
I mean, you can watch it if you want or get
those messages if you want, but you actually
set up a way to reward people who tend to
be more balanced and normal in their conversation.
OK, now the energy and social media rewards
the more aggressive or sensationalistic yourself.
Except it again, you just like, keep it, keep
it even keeled.
And yet everyone loves you.
Speaker 1: Well, you should see the emails
I get.
But so it sounds like you're not saying you
would be in favor of the government going
to YouTube and saying you've got to live up
anti-vaccine content.
Speaker 4: Oh, there there are certain things
that you'd have to say are in the public good
that, you know, and there's disinformation
and there's disinformation that can be destructive
in a way that, you know, like if you are functioning
society, you do not want to say like every
idea is the same, including ideas that, by
the way, in this case could lead people to
lose their lives.
Speaker 1: So, so in other words, you want
to make it easier to control one's experience
on these platforms, but not take the approach
that some on the right are saying, which is
these these platforms should be forced to
allow content that violates their terms of
service again, as long as it's not illegal
on the basis of discrimination on race or
sex or this type of thing.
Speaker 4: Well, I want to echo what some
of the social media CEOs themselves say, which
is like, why are we in a position to make
this decision?
And the reason they're making that decision
is because the government is absent.
One of the social media CEOs said, Look, we
should get together tech, government, media,
nonprofits and set rules of the road.
So it's not just us doing the content moderation
decision and you yelling at us about it because
wherever they draw the line, they're going
to get yelled at.
You know, I happen to think the Conservatives
are off base in terms of saying like, Oh,
you know, you're sledging conservative content.
It's like conservative content actually performs
great on a lot of these platforms.
And if there's anything we should be concerned
about, it's the deteriorating mental health
of our young people, teenage girls in particular.
So if you're a conservative, I get mad about
that in my mind, right?
Yeah.
Being depressed, like, isn't that a bigger
issue than the fact that, you know, anyway?
Speaker 1: And I guess then the question would
become if Facebook knew that was going on
and was hiding it for a period of time.
Are they really good faith players to be involved
in figuring out the regulation, which is sort
of a second order question?
Speaker 4: Well, they can be at the table,
but we should stop pretending that companies
are going to do anything other than what's
going to maximize their financial returns,
which is exactly what you'd expect them to
do.
So.
So if you have that expectation and then you
go in and say, Hey, guess what?
We're going to do things that are going to
make your financial returns lower and tough
luck, you know?
And so one thing I suggested as like a random
thing, it's like maybe Instagram's a turnoff
for teenagers between midnight and 7:00 a.m.
like, you know, maybe just looking at pictures
of your high school classmates or something
we don't want you to do in the middle of the
night, you know, like, you know, just like
a random thought.
And so you can see that kind of like with
Facebook, we're excited about that.
Of course not.
They'd be like, Oh, we make money, then we
make money all the time, right?
You know, hopefully
Speaker 1: the book is forward notes on the
future of our democracy.
I really appreciate reading the book, and
we've been speaking with the book's author,
Andrew Yang.
Always great having you on, and I really appreciate
your time.
Speaker 4: Thank you, Dave.
It's great to be back.